[Music]
I don't think you deserve to die no it's
a shame how that happened I swear I
didn't mean to don't lecture me Pavarti
I do it I want let's get out of here
here we go baby
[Music]
this is very much a dirty arty ships yes
yes the unreliable the unreliable but
I'm about to ruin your day according to
your ship's record you've been flagged
by the board your ship will be impounded
until such a time as they see fit to
live I'm gonna wring your scrawny neck
you Spratt
[Laughter]
welcome back to dirty RT to the show
where we make the biggest piece of debt
ever and we play has him or her but in
this case it's him it's dirty RT in
outer worlds Jake this is episode 3 now
episode 3 episode 3 and we have to make
money we have to make money in order to
pursue the the main storyline with
GLaDOS
you picked a hell of a day to visit I'm
Vaughn Vaughn Cortez dr. Vaughn Cortez
but just Falls fine really
over in the main labs I rabbit it back
here when I realized I was hearing
gunshots not blown fuses we've been
cooped up in here I don't know hours too
long I have to get back to work huh you
look nervous what I mean we're
surrounded by hungry Raptor Don's who
wouldn't be
am i right look I don't want to go back
out there but there's a thing I gotta do
I had to leave an experiment running at
the lab something I've been working on a
long while something that could really
get me ahead know what I mean
no do you explain the details please
I've been extracting organic compounds
from rapid Ahn's compounds that have
benefits extracting how no wait maybe I
don't want to know in certain social
situations personal situations where you
might want to enhance your charisma Oh
for he's making enraptured captain and
aphrodisiac
wrapped Musk is the main ingredient what
no I mean yes I'm getting the musk with
monarch embargo the price is sky-high
but I'm not making the drug does it work
the results are outside the margin of
error just can where are the two labs
well scare
[Music]
there's little tick every time you look
at someone feel like you're gonna you're
gonna swing outlaws I assume do me a
favor and let me finish this will you
and then make it quick please
make one quick action my death you
simpleton whoa I feel like we have to do
I feel like you have to Oh trickster
hopefully that didn't cause any problems
I think we're good
he shot first I'm a locksmith whoa heavy
machine gun oh I'll do it
oh hell he has been sick Oh hold still
oh wow she really did I show you all
right you guys are good hopes to Allah
Oh
dang I like the sword mm-hmm oh you yeah
you just bleep himself
you care to explain what you're doing
here did you miss the big sign outside
let me judge you funny way to phrase it
yeah I'm supposed to be chief Porter I
work security for the company bad news
is we haven't been able to clean these
outlaws out of the lab good news is they
have been able to escape neither
oh god yeah go get em send them both out
there
Oh
[Music]
and [ __ ] up there that girl attack
fantastic leadership
whoa
they're both down Oh God odd don't come
in here
Oh what hell yeah oh hell yeah I really
thought you were dead I thought I was
too yeah
feel it Oh what is it what is it we
found a flaw physical physical damage
weakness all right should we just have
that look dirty already looking at my
poison hey Dale I like it but it's weird
we should just take every flaw yeah we
have to wow that was a hell of a fight
you want that Joel actuator no you're
okay yeah thanks for the help
jackass
[Music]
can I hit hit the secrets
you owe me over here oh good you're not
shooting at me that's a start it's been
a bit of a day so I'll get to the point
yes I have cranes research no I'm not
giving it back sorry to disappoint you
you play dumb I don't know you're
talking about I don't know I don't know
you're talking about I suppose it does
not matter either crane sent you or you
are some scavenger come to rob me in my
moment of weakness let's make a deal I'd
like to go on living you'd probably like
to make some money help me get out of
here and I will pay you for your trouble
the first thing I need is a key card to
unlock my door
then I'd need you to clear me a path out
of here there are two ways out the
quickest is through the front door but
Cleo Security's bottled up in there if
you don't want to shoot them I suppose
you could talk to them you threatening
me goddamn turncoat we saw everything
what here spread your cheese Oh
[Applause]
so I I did this part I screwed it up I
like turned I like thought I could like
mess with the computer and I turned all
this on I ruined the experiment' you can
like you could feasibly finish the
experiment I think and like kinda know
get some cool results out of it but I
just just do it
turn it around just just attempt to be
artis I just push buttons don't press
button I press button press other
buttons I have I mean I think I think
the other button didn't work I think it
did
oh my god it worked you got the Musk I'm
a scientist now good give me a lab coat
I should work here hey I'm gonna get a
fear of heights because I'd always
jumping that's fun then we got a play on
that no it's clear oh I got this
put your dogs on the leash
oh that one got a little layer didn't it
get him get him girls get him I need a
kill three who's countin gosh I thought
I picked it up I don't remember who she
said it who had it a little recap Anton
is dead Wilson is dead
I can no longer provide you with any
information I don't know where I don't
know what she said is it on Porter that
guy I thought I picked it up I would ask
what was on your mind but the answer is
obviously me I blacked out what am i
doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know I might be able to do mmm
I think I think I know how we can do
this if I can figure out where I am
okay here we go
she's got a gun in her and she's locked
up Oh what Oh everyone's pissed now you
just sight there oh yeah he'll get up
you'll recover okay maybe I can reach
through the bars on the other hand and
grab the data yeah oh wow wow I'm
impressed I'm impressed that works out
[Music]
so this is where even like gasps all the
rapid dawns Wow we're not going in there
are we I'm not going in there but you
are oh boy who's your mama
screaming you can do it we'll help you
we'll get a couple swings here there you
go you can do the rest
[Laughter]
Wow well I killed everyone for no reason
[Applause]
if you're here for this week's magazine
club meeting know
[Music]
what's that speak up now I said would
you turn up
yeah eat it too you gotta figure that
Musk
these corporations I tell you once they
get an idea into their big dense heads
there's no getting it out again
can't imagine how I'll float this but
always not really not I suppose
[Music]
well ain't that peachy you enjoy that
stamp you understand and don't you dare
use it responsibly anything else
oh my law you've done it you've saved my
hide I can't thank you enough
nothing let me see I just have to apply
the seal here sound like so and tada
here are the forms you need once you
reach Byzantium oh and an Ave key so you
should can travel there
those authorization forms will let you
speak with Sophia when you arrive I'll
send her a message straight away to let
her know you're coming
should be delighted I'm sure you mean
the lady who handles the Chairman's
business or the third most powerful
person in the colony all right they're
the same person yes quite miss akanda is
just the person to take someone with
your particular talents and centeral in
character under her wing she can fill
you in on all the board's operations in
the colony really put your talents to
use best of luck to you and thank you
again give my regards to the unreliable
well that's gonna do it for this episode
of dirty RT we did a lot today we did we
made we made a lot of money we killed a
lot of people we used some bizarre way I
think the clutches moment was when you
killed that that woman was older and
reached between that was amazing in this
game is pretty awesome for allowing that
to happen so fantastic stuff I think
we're gonna continue our quests I guess
now to to lock up Phineas Wells yep turn
it on him or turn in we're gonna we're
gonna slide with the board temporarily
and then I don't know I don't think
we're gonna you know dirty already works
for no person but he's definitely using
people at this stage is easy smart
enough he he he's got a little bit of
intelligence I think he's in early doing
it but that's gonna do if this episode
thank you guys so much we'll see y'all
next week take care of five
[Music]
you